>> Tucker: THE FIRST
INDICATION THAT WEST MIGHT
BECOME A MASSIVE PROBLEM FOR THE
INDUSTRIAL DECEPTION COMPLEX
CAME IN 2016 AND 2015 WHEN TRUMP
APPEARED AND WEST HAD A STRONG
GUT REACTION TO HIM THAT WAS
POSITIVE AND THE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM WERE PANICKED BY THIS.
THE LAST THING YOU COULD HAVE AS
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR POP
CULTURE FIGURES IN AMERICA
COMING OUT FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THEY APPLIED INTENSE PRESSURE TO
GET HIM BACK ON THE SCRIPT AND
HIS FORMER WIFE WAS A PART OF
THAT, KIM KARDASHIAN WHO NOW
WEST NOW LEARNED HAD A VERY
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CLINTONS AND PEOPLE AROUND THE
CLINTONS.
HE HAD NO IDEA.
HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH TRUMP
FLOURISHED AND HE GOT A WINDOW
INTO THE PEOPLE AROUND TRUMP.
IN THIS CLIP YOU WILL HEAR HIM
ASSESS WHAT HAPPENED INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE, VERY INTERESTING --
WATCH.
>> IT WAS INTERESTING, FRIEND OF
MINE TOLD ME THAT CHRIS AND KIM
HAD CALLED HIM BECAUSE HE HAD
INFLUENCE INSIDE THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
AND HAD CALLED HIM TO SAY, TO
GET HIM TO INFLUENCE PEOPLE TO
TAKE THE VACCINATION.
AND I DON'T HAVE OPINION ON THAT
I JUST WANTED TO STATE THAT AS A
STATEMENT.
IT WAS WILD THAT I DIDN'T KNOW
HOW CLOSE MY OWN WIFE WAS TO THE
CLINTONS -- I DIDN'T KNOW, I
DIDN'T REALIZE IT AT THE TIME.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE MARRIED TO
HER.
>> I WAS MARRIED TO HER.
>> HOW CLOSE WAS SHE TO THE
CLINTONS?
>> CELL PHONE AWAY OR TELL YE TO
SAY THIS OR USE YOUR PLATFORM TO
PUSH THE VACCINATION AWAY.
>> Tucker: DO YOU FEEL AT
TIMES YOU WERE MANIPULATED BY
POLITICAL FORCES THROUGH YOUR
WIFE.
>> ATTEMPTED MANIPULATION, ME
NOT SAYING I LIKED TRUMP WAS A
FORM OF MANIPULATION.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
WHY DID YOU LIKE HIM?
YOU SAID YOU LIKED HIM EARLY.
>> I KEEP TELLING THIS JOKE, IF
PEOPLE KEEP SAYING HE WAS THE
FIRST BLACK PRESIDENT I'M GOING
TO BE THE FIRST LATINO PRESIDENT
BECAUSE ALL OF THE VALUES THE
CONSERVATIVE VALUES LINEUP.
HE SAYS [BLEEP] -- HE HAS HIS
OWN BUILDINGS, WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
HE MADE IVANKA.
>> Tucker: YOU LIKE IVANKA.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: YOU WROTE A POST ON
INSTAGRAM ABOUT HER HUSBAND
TODAY.
>> YEAH, I HAD A DINNER WITH
IVANKA, JARED, AND JOSH.
A COUPLE DAYS LATER I FOUND OUT
THAT JOSH HAD A 10% OF SCAMS
WHICH IS A LINE I HAD DEVELOPED
WITH KIM AND I HAD A LOT OF
ISSUES WITH THE IMAGERY -- I
FELT LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
IMAGERY THAT WAS OPENLY
SEXUALIZED AND THINGS I WANT
WANT TO SEE MY WIFE AND
DEFINITELY NOT MY DAUGHTERS
DOING IN THE FUTURE IN ORDER TO
SELL PRODUCT.
IT REACHES ANOTHER LEVEL WHEN
IT'S LIKE THIS IS WHAT MY WIFE
IS DOING, THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE
DOING -- THIS IS WHAT SHE IS
DOING FOR OUR CHILDREN.
IT REACHES ANOTHER LEVEL IN HER
BUSINESS PARTNERS ARE SELLING
PIECES OF COMPANY THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BECAUSE THE COMPANY IS
ALREADY SUCCESSFUL.
INTERNET BASED COMPANY, THEY ARE
REALLY JUST SELLING OFF THE
COMPANY IN ORDER TO CREATE MORE
RELATIONSHIPS FOR THEMSELVES
THAT ARE UNNEEDED.
IT'S LIKE WHEN I WENT TO THE GAP
AND THEY SHOVELED IT OUT -- I'M
VERY CAUTIOUS WITH MY WORDS.
I'M REALLY BIG ON BEING ABLE TO
HAVE AN ADULT CONVERSATION IN
FRONT OF THE CHILDREN.
I DON'T USE EXPLICIT LANGUAGE IN
INTERVIEWS ESPECIALLY.
I FOUND OUT AFTER THIS DINNER
THAT JOSH KUSHNER HAD 10% OF
SCAMS AND I HAD 5% AND
REGARDLESS IF HE FIGURED OUT HOW
TO PUT $150 MILLION -- I'M SURE
IT WASN'T OUT OF HIS OWN ACCOUNT
BUT 150 MILLION AND I'M SURE
JERROD STILL HAS A PIECE OF THAT
FUND, REGARDLESS OF THEM PUTTING
THAT MONEY IN, FOR ME TO HAVE
BEEN AN OWNER AND NOT KNOWN JUST
FROM A PLACE AS A CREATIVE WHERE
SKIMS IS SO BASED ON A LOT OF
THE IDEAS, THEN IT'S BASED ON
ALL OF THE RELATIONSHIPS IN
FASHION BECAUSE I HAD TO USE MY
RELATIONSHIPS IN FASHION IN
ORDER TO ESTABLISH KIM IN A WAY
WHERE FASHIONABLE PEOPLE WOULD
SAY I'M DOWN TO WHERE KIM'S LINE
AND THESE VCS COME IN AND GET A
PIECE OF IT AFTER THE FACT AND
THEY RUN AROUND AND SAY THEY
HAVE OWNERSHIP.
AS A POINT ON MY INSTAGRAM WHICH
LUCKILY FOR EVERYONE THEY CAN
JUST WRITE IT OFF THAT I'M CRAZY
UNTIL THEY SEE MY DISPOSITION IN
THIS INTERVIEW AND THEN IT'S
GOING TO GET SCARY.
I SAID JOSH, WHAT IF I HAD 10%
OF CARLY COSTS' LINGERIE SHAPE
WHERE SWIMSUIT LINE AND YOU HAVE
5% OF IT AND YOU DIDN'T KNOW?
HOW WOULD THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
AND THEN AFTER TALKING TO THEM
AND REALLY SITTING WITH JARED
AND SITTING WITH JOSH AND
FINDING OUT OTHER PIECES OF
INFORMATION I WAS LIKE WOW,
THESE GUYS MIGHT HAVE REALLY
BEEN HOLDING TRUMP BACK AND
BEING A HANDLER.
THEY LOVE TO LOOK AT ME OR LOOK
AT TRUMP LIKE WE ARE SO CRAZY
AND THEY ARE THE BUSINESSMEN.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT JARED DOESN'T GET
ENOUGH CREDIT FOR WITH HIS
WORK -- HIS WORK IN ISRAEL, WHAT
IS THIS, YOU KNOW WHAT HE MADE
PEACE TREATIES, YOU KNOW THE
FACTS ON THIS RIGHT HERE?
>> ISRAEL AND SOME OF THE OTHER
ARAB NATIONS.
>> I THINK IT WAS TO MAKE MONEY.
IS TOO HEAVY-HANDED TO PUT IN
THIS PLATFORM?
>> THAT IS YOUR OPINION, WE ARE
NOT IN THE CENSORSHIP BUSINESS.
>> THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
ABOUT IS MAKING MONEY, I DON'T
THINK THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAKE ANYTHING ON THEIR OWN I
THINK THEY WERE BORN INTO MONEY.
FOR ME AS A MAVERICK AND A
TALENT AND A PERSON THAT HAS
BEEN BEATEN, KICKED, LOST
EVERYTHING, SAID TO HAVE LOST MY
MIND, WENT FROM PULL MYSELF UP
UP FROM MY BOOTS TO BECOMING A
MULTIBILLIONAIRE -- THE PRICE
EVERY YEAR OF MY NETWORK GOES
DOWN EVERY YEAR ON FORBES, THEY
KEEP SLOWLY TAKING IT DOWN EVERY
YEAR.
IT'S A WEIRD THING.
A PERSON WHO HAS BUILT SOMETHING
FROM NOTHING WHEN I SIT ACROSS
THE TABLE FROM JOSH KUSHNER AND
HE FEELS SO ENTITLED TO THAT
IDEA AND THIS PERSON HAS NEVER
BROUGHT ANYTHING OF VALUE OTHER
THAN BEING A GOOD VENTURE
CAPITALIST, I HAVE A MAJOR ISSUE
WITH THAT.
IT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE THEY
WEREN'T SERVING MY BOY TRUMP THE
WAY WE COULD HAVE.
TRUMP WANTED NOTHING BUT THE
BEST FOR THIS COUNTRY.
MOSES STUTTERED.
GOD ISN'T ALWAYS GOING TO BRING
THE MOST PERFECT PERSONALITY.
A LOT OF TIMES THE MOST FAKE
PEOPLE, THEIR JOB IS TALKING AND
MAKING PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE.
AND THE REALIST PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO MAKE YOU FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
AT FIRST.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT SHALLOW
AND IT'S ALSO NOT CRAZY, IT'S
TRUE.
WHETHER YOU AGREE WITH IT OR
NOT.
WEST HAS THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT
POLITICS AND HE THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
2024, YOU HEAR THAT COMING UP.
HE'S ALSO CLOSE TO ELON MUSK
WHICH